-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night".
How's everybody doing tonight?
[ Audience cheering ]
That's great to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
The House of Representatives
voted yesterday
to remove
Speaker Kevin McCarthy.
Well, Kevin, don't cry
because it's over,
cry because it happened.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
the House voted yesterday
to remove a speaker
from power
for the first time
in 234 years.
Well, they removed him
from office.
It's hard to have power
when you have all the fire
and charisma of
the Facebook silhouette guy.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at his face.
This is a man
who either got removed --
He either got removed
as speaker
or was just called
his brother's name in bed.
[ Laughter ]
[ Mimicking McCarthy ]
"Do I -- Do I say something
or do I just let it go?"
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration
announced today
that it will forgive $9 billion
in student loans.
"Well, that should at least
cover most of it",
said one NYU kid.
[ Laughter, applause ]
[ Mimicking NYU kid ] "Still
probably need to get a job."
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
Manhattan Supreme Court
Judge Arthur Engorgon --
Uh, no, that's Engoron,
sorry.
Manhattan Supreme Court
Judge Arthur Engoron
placed a limited gag order
yesterday
on former President Trump
for his civil fraud trial,
which, if violated,
carries a penalty
of up to 30 days in jail.
Seriously? The guy eats
nothing but fast food
and lives in a Florida
swamp hotel.
You're not going to
break him with jail.
[ Laughter ]
He'll come out rested and ready
with three new lawyers.
[ Laughter ]
During his civil fraud
trial yesterday,
former President Trump's son,
Eric,
was reportedly seen
biting his nails,
but Trump put a stop to it.
[ Laughter ]
Police in Slovakia recently
shared a traffic camera photo
of what appears
to be a dog
behind the wheel
of a speeding car.
He got pulled over, but he
swears the light was gray.
[ Laughter ]
It's a good joke.
It's a good joke...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...about dogs being colorblind.
Scotland's took the funniest
picture of the day
and found a very boring thing
to drill down on.
[ Laughter ]
Today was International Walk
to School Day.
This news first reported
by a hungover mom.
[ Laughter ]
[ Mimicking woman ]
"Hey, good news.
It's a holiday."
[ Laughter ]
"Shhhhh."
Taco Bell announced
yesterday it will offer
a so-called taco lover pass
that allows customers
to get a taco every day
for one month for just $10.
So if you love tacos,
maybe you try
getting them somewhere
other than Taco Bell.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Taco Bell
will offer customers a $10 pass
that allows them to get one taco
every day for one month,
though it's never a good sign
when your promotion
sounds like a punishment
from a parent in the 1950's.
[ Mimicking parent ]
"Oh, you like tacos?
We'll see how much you like
tacos in a month, wise guy."
[ Laughter ]
[ Mimicking child ]
"What a day."
[ Laughter ]
Google announced yesterday
it may no longer deliver e-mails
from users whose messages
are frequently marked as spam.
In other news,
Crate & Barrel's stock
plunged more than 30% today.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Paramount Pictures yesterday
uploaded the entire movie
"Mean Girls"
onto the social media platform
TikTok.
But if you really want
to see "Mean Girls" on TikTok,
just read the comments.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We're up and running.